the Jeep Wrangler is a classic off-road
vehicle the special model Unlimited is a
longer version of the Wrangler it has
four doors and seats up to five
passengers the long version costs an
additional three thousand euros in
Germany the one we're testing is a
special model commemorating jeeps 75th
birthday in 1941 the Willy's MB the
original Jeep was developed for the US
Army for use in World War two so this
birthday edition is dressed up in
military style Sarge green paint with
bronze colored 18-inch alloy wheel rims
and lettering
they often are contests Amata's curette
says that the exterior paint job is the
most conspicuous difference between the
last Jeep Wrangler he drove in 2011 and
this one the last one was blue what
hasn't changed the montes pretends to
feel insulted because he mentioned this
problem and his test drive last time is
how troublesome it is to open the roof
you start by unzipping the windows it's
a bit of a hassle you repeat the
procedure on the other side then you
have to deal with a plastic window at
the back it's important to work from
right to left not left to right or you
won't be able to remove the window then
you have to move back to the front and
release these hooks above the windshield
these next then you released the next
latch
look he had another that needs to be
released too and then you have to tidy
up and fold everything together or it
looks like total chaos the Jeep Wrangler
Unlimited is available with a gasoline
or diesel engine the 2.8 liter
common-rail diesel engine and our test
car produces 147 kilowatts overall fuel
consumption is 9.1 liters per 100
kilometers the vehicle sells for forty
nine thousand four hundred seventy five
euros in Germany Martha says little has
changed in the interior in recent years
probably the only thing that's different
about sitting in the car now from a few
years ago is that he has less hair the
Jeep is very robust and clearly
organized there's a handle for the front
passenger to hold on to when the chief
has taken off road the windows are still
controlled from the center panel montes
finds that a bit confusing his impulse
is to reach toward the door because
that's where most cars have the window
buttons so it just takes a little
getting used to
here is the automatic shift and the
lever for all-wheel-drive and off-road
gear reduction the mirrors are electric
which is nice although you don't adjust
them all that often Montes is very
pleased that the Wranglers straight
lines make it easy to see everything
around the car this Wrangler Zia hoot
su Montes says most SUVs have electronic
locks in the like but the Wrangler
provides a lever allowing the driver to
shift from rear wheel to all-wheel drive
and to get off road gear reduction
electronic locks are then involved - and
that makes it possible to drive in
really rough terrain even with the
normal road tires that are on this
vehicle in Fonseca office this car is
really made for roughing it
mata said he wouldn't even try to drive
in here with another car not only
because it wouldn't be possible but also
because he'd be afraid of severely
damaging the vehicle only the Wrangler
goes beyond off-road appearance to
achieve this real off-road performance
Montez is impressed he drives through
woods and meadows underbrush and rocky
terrain no problem mother says the Jeep
Wrangler is not one of these modern SUVs
that use electronic aids to produce a
little bit of off-road capacity the
Wrangler is a genuine tough-as-nails
all-terrain vehicle Montes would even
bet it's the best off-road vehicle
available today for non-military use
kolenda wagon food in civilian Einsatz
Dena's back to Elliot the Wrangler an
off-road vehicle that is most impressive
off the beaten path
you